بالنسبة لنا، من الواضح أن نقطة البداية هي نحن
لم يعد لديهم في أيديهم
ويجب أن يكون الهدف الآن 15
للحصول على نقاط وإذا كنا كذلك تماما
يتم إبلاغها بوضوح إذا استمر هذا
لعب يتمايل جدا و
كيف كان الأخيرين
سنكون قد لعبنا مباريات الدوري الألماني
إذا لم نتمكن من القيام بذلك، علينا أن نتحسن
ولم يفت الأوان بعد لكسب و
لإظهار رد الفعل هذا الذي نحتاجه
أنت مباشرة يوم الأحد وسنكون هناك
نحن لن نسمح لأي شخص بالخروج بعد الآن أيضًا
سوف إذا كان هذا سوف نقوم به
لا تدع أحدا يفوتك يوم الأحد
هذا الالتزام وبعد ذلك هو يوم الاثنين
تدريب الثلاثاء التدريب وبعد ذلك سوف
يبدأ مرة أخرى يوم الأربعاء
الفريق يعرف ذلك ونحن جميعا نعرف ذلك
هذا وذاك يجب أن يفعل ذلك الآن مهما كانت الطريقة
ما مدى صعوبة خلاف ذلك
يجب أن تخترق